hey youtubers is charlie because the
doctor who christmas special is this
week and there's so much talk about
Clara leaving I thought it'd be fun to
pick a new companion heads up to a new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card I just
pick at random the way it reads right
now Clara is probably gonna stay on for
up to half a series nine maybe less than
that Jenna Coleman has been very cryptic
about it but Moffat spent so much time
talking about children and teasing Frank
Skinner and orient express this year
they'll apply be someone new whenever
series nine starts off they did a
preview screening of the Christmas
special a couple weeks ago and it was
revealed that series 9 episode 1 is
titled The Magician's apprentice do you
not just love how much Moffitt and
Capaldi are leaning into this magician
joke can you just feel all the
out-of-work Harry Potter actors queuing
up at Moffitt store whatever ends up
happening Clara's leaving soon so
everybody get your doctor Clara
regeneration jokes ready I can just feel
waves of puns coming off of a tumblr so
I already talked a little bit about
people I'd like to seek as companions on
Doctor Who before series 8 started but
because of the way things went down and
the overall tone of the show in the
direction i think it should go in i
tried to adjust some of my pics i really
love the idea of evil clara so i'd like
to see a more rugged companion maybe not
necessarily evil companion but someone
who could play evil in a really fun way
without stepping on michelle Gomez's
toes and just because I'd like to see a
tougher companion like a more physically
imposing companion doesn't mean I'm
stuck on it being male but if we're
talking about a female doctor happening
soon then we should also talk about a
male companion happening soon so here
are my top five picks for new companions
starting with number five Ellis George
as Courtney woods she doesn't really fit
into my idea of a battle-ready companion
but I feel like Moffat was keeping her
locked in the chamber of his gun all
year just in case Jenna Coleman pulled
the trigger there was a good chance that
she was gonna leave in the Christmas
special so I think he was just having
someone queued up ready to go think of
Courtney woods is like the safety pick
so that's why I put her on this list
she's like the default right now until
Moffat finds a better companion we don't
really know what his actual plans are
for series 9 other than he's really
leaning into the idea of Capaldi being a
wizard which I am all on board for I'm
totally on board for the doctor being a
wizard number four Matthew
Louis from Harry Potter you probably
remember him is neville longbottom but
right now he's on bluestone playing a
soldier so he fits really well into my
idea of a magician's apprentice he's
played with a wand but look at him now I
mean he is literally in a war zone that
doesn't mean I want Capaldi to turn into
a war doctor I just I want the doctor to
be more aggressive I want the show to be
more aggressive I really enjoyed the
dark stories during series 8 I think
it's a lot more fun whenever the doctor
charges in and causes more problems than
he solves and think about his distaste
for soldiers it seems a little
irrational at times but I feel like
having one onboard the TARDIS would just
cause the scenes to crackle with energy
someone who has the self-confidence to
not put up with any of the doctors
bullcrap and who's not going to shy away
from a fight it'd just be so much fun to
see companion who could punch someone in
the face that's not really what doctor
who is about but I would like to see it
drift slowly in that direction at least
for one series I'm all for the idea of
Doctor Who characters solving their
problems using ingenuity but it would be
nice to see them use some muscle every
once in a while number four Ellie
Kendrick from Game of Thrones I'm mostly
put on this list because of what she did
on misfits her Helen character she did a
really good job of playing both good and
evil characters and that's what I feel
like a companion should be car only got
a little bit evil but she was a lot of
fun she was a lot of fun when she was
being crazy and that's totally Ellie
Kendrick on misfits I mean all those
characters were crazy I'm really leaning
towards a male companion for the most
part but I feel like she would be an
amazing magician's apprentice the added
bonus is she's not so big she's not
blowing it up so hardcore that she's too
expensive for Doctor Who and she's not
too busy for it that's one of the big
problems with a lot of the great actors
is there already signed to other series
or they're starting their film careers
that's why Matt Smith left I mean his
film career was taking off so Ellie
Kendrick just checks all those boxes and
I feel like Game of Thrones could do
without her like it doesn't need her
number to Alexander Ludwig from Vikings
right now he's the adult son of Ragnar
and LeGarrette on the show it'd be a
little harder to get him just because
he's still alive on the show and they're
shooting a new season but because they
also shoot in the UK he's a little
closer to Cardiff that's another big
problem too lots of great actors out
there but you have to be in proximity to
Cardiff because that's where doctor who
shoots really any number of actors from
Vikings would be awesome
just like a really badass tough
companion I'd say lagarza too but I feel
like she's too critical to that show
like they're not gonna kill her off on
Vikings anytime soon and my number one
picked for a new Doctor Who companion
Joe Dempsie from Game of Thrones
although he's done a bunch other stuff
recently a lot of people might remember
him from the doctor's daughter during
david tennant's run there have been a
lot of actors on Doctor Who that have
played lesser characters and gone on to
become the doctor themselves like in
classic ooh so there is precedent for
actors that have already been on the
show to come back in a different role
but I feel like Joe Dempsie can bring
the perfect kind of energy that I'm
looking for the downside to having him
as awesome as that be is that that might
not be the direction that Moffat wants
to take the show in really the title
that magician's apprentice title makes
it sound like it's going to be a harry
potter spin-off they do like to have fun
with titles and to be honest a lot of
the titles change during series 8 like
there were titles that we got early in
the year some of those change some of
those stayed the same so it's probably
to be a long time before we know what's
going down especially given that Moffat
lies so much and I say that in the
nicest possible way let me know that who
is your top pick for a new companion do
you want to see a male companion do you
want to see another female companion
someone older someone younger there's a
good chance that the campaign could show
up in the first episode of series 9 and
they're going to be shooting that after
they shoot the Sherlock Christmas
special in January so that's coming up
really soon here a couple things that I
think will absolutely not happen one I
don't think it's going to be an old
companion I think it'll be someone
closer to Jenna Coleman sage if not
younger number two it's not going to be
a really young child I don't think
they'll go to Amelia pond route I could
just feel the rage from all the
cringe-worthy moments from having like
little children on screen all the time
Clara and Danny pink at coal Hill School
was totally awesome in series 8 it was
totally awesome to see the inside of
that all the students not so much and
three it's not going to be someone with
potential for hanky panky there will be
no hanky-panky on the TARDIS as the
doctor said just to do some fictional
casting just have some fun and we'll
Williams and Alfie Owens that's the
daughter of Gwen Cooper from Torchwood
and Stormageddon I'd really like to see
some fan fiction where they start like a
kid's detective agency and start causing
a bunch of trouble and the doctor has to
get involved because they uncover some
game of thrones level galactic that
also be an awesome way to bring John
Barrowman back into the story Steven
Moffat actually said he's totally opened
having Captain Jack back on the show but
only if his presence invigorates the
story like he's not gonna bring him on
just for fun so a couple important dates
to remember doctor who christmas special
happening on the twenty-fifth everyone
be sure to watch it I will be posting my
review like right after the episode airs
and then I'll be posting a QA after that
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll try and do some more
bonus videos too but it will continue
the giveaway for like all mine on Q&A
videos like all the bonus videos and
their views I post including this one
congratulations to it's the real music
band you're the winner of this week's
giveaway you win a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card so be sure to message me on my
channel for details next round of the
giveaway will start whenever I post my
Christmas special review i might post a
bonus video tomorrow so if i do then
there'll be another round at the
giveaway then i'm also working on a
Sherlock bonus video that i'll try and
post sometime in the next couple of days
to doctor who has priority but i will be
doing Sherlock to right now if you're on
your mobile phone on your tablet there's
new links you can click on up here it's
the same as the links over here but
click here for all my doctor who
christmas special videos and click here
to start getting ready for Sherlock
thank you so much for watching plus all
high five I'll see you guys tonight